[Music]
so could uh could you please say your
full name into the microphone patricia
williams lee it's my full name
i kept my maiden name in case he don't
act right so i just drop his name
instead of changing the [__]
is easy to dropped and change
well
patricia williams lee yes no middle name
thank you for being on the show well
thank you for having me what is your
name i am joel byers okay you never told
me your name and if you did i forgot
yes i am joel byers i'm hosting the hot
breath podcast here
so let's hop into it where did you first
perform stand-up comedy at a place here
in atlanta called the pub
how old were you
oh i don't [__] know i was in my 20s
i was like 30. i think i was like
uh 15 years about 13 years about i was
in my early 30s when i started wow which
is old as [__] and i had no idea
and you automatically think oh i made
these people laugh i'm gonna be famous
in two weeks it doesn't work like that
you don't know what the [__] you doing
the first time you go on stage all i did
was just cussed out this white girl and
made it it was really funny i was
joining her you know no joke yeah
roasting roasting her and people was
like oh that she was so funny i was like
i am a comedian but i was like [__] the
[__] up
i didn't know what the hell i was doing
did you do any performing as a kid at
all
uh uh and i was being a mama and in jail
as a kid but you did some like at the
growing up at the bootleg house didn't
you entertain some there yeah it was
called dancing for drunk people
so if i was gonna use that lesson i
would have been a stripper a stripper
[Laughter]
so i didn't want to use that lesson
that's why i never danced i hate [__]
dancing i go right back to the bootleg
house and i was like i hate this [__]
so i grew up doing it for drunk people
and nasty looking old men it was like oh
pop that ass baby
pop that ass baby that don't even sound
like this no but you were a baby when it
was happening i was well i was about
eight yeah and i could pop my ass too
so there were hecklers back then as well
uh no it was [__] that wanted to [__]
you back then
i just wanted to rub on your undeveloped
chest
wow
at least can appreciate their honesty
[Laughter]
that's why every hood got a ding-a-ling
man to get you ready for the real world
i'm quite sure you didn't have a
ding-a-ling man you white
they would arrest your dingley man they
didn't give a [__] about the dingling
man in the ghetto
he kept the kids in in line they go to
dangling man white kids chase the ice
cream truck black kids run away from the
dangling man at least there was a
neighborhood watch
[Laughter]
you know i tell my kids i said back then
kids didn't really get kidnapped like
they do now i was like what where the
[__] happened to the good old dangling
man the person who'll pick you up rub on
your booty get your files and bring you
back home
[Laughter]
there's no more digging man they call
them child molesters now they call them
everything's so pc now
yeah yeah
one pc when i was giving birth at 14. oh
wow
well at least you didn't you grew up and
got your chops early you could say
because yeah they was given to you you
didn't have a choice
what i've noticed interviewing
a lot of comics from atlanta is we all
have
a boo story getting booed on stage
what's yours
um
i've i had a dude to try me one time we
was doing like open mic over in the um
new orleans style restaurant over peace
tree copelands so they used to do comedy
there at night
and it was this dude that was booming
the place used to be paint nobody really
listened to comedy but he was booming
behind a wall and he had a skull cap on
and i lit his ass up
so i mean i've never been i don't think
i've been booed where i had to just lead
the stage i always fought back so
what was what's the story about you
having nerf balls thrown at you uh
that's oh my god
i was uh i was with my friend double d
you know double don't know you a comic
from atlanta so he signed me up because
i have been doing i have been doing open
mic for about two three months so we
over at grill from he was refused to be
on v103 at that time so we go to his
room and uh if the people don't like you
they throw these nerf balls at you i
didn't know that so as the people come
into the comedy spot they get they they
pay their ticket money and they get they
give them as many nerf balls as they
want so double d signed me up and i
looked at it he's like come to the
stadium i'm like who [__] been proud
like that's me i'm like [__] you sign
me up he's like yeah you gotta start
going on stage more so i get up there i
don't know the [__] i'm doing nervous
because i've never really been in front
of a real comedy crowd
and i'm not doing well and so this young
dude look nice dress black gentleman hit
me in my forehead with a [__] nerf
ball and i'm from the hood i'm i'm a
battered [__] you don't [__] hit me
and i said [__] did you just hit me in
my head never [__] ball i said hit me
again [__] i'ma jump off this stage and
i'm gonna smash your [__] ass
with that turtleneck on and
i picked that ball up and i hit that
sumbitch in the chest and the crowd just
went right that was my first standing
ovation running jordan big ass in the
corner hollering screaming and i said i
couldn't believe that [__] hit
me with that and it wasn't no regular it
was nerf ball that kind of you bounce on
the ground that [__] hit me and
put a dent in my forehead and i got a
big foe here that [__] brew all
i had a flashback of my baby daddy
beating me i said [__] hit me with
another ball and it's gonna be on the
day and then i jumped up and said [__]
that [__] y'all let's rob this [__]
why i wanted to rob somebody at a
company show i don't know
i don't know what man cause i was gonna
rob him right cause i had just gotta
like come out of the streets you don't
[__] put your hands on me dude i work
too hard to keep a [__] hands
off me that mother put his hand on me i
tried oh my god i said y'all let's rob
this [__]
he was so scared of me and he had on
them big turtleneck i said they hit me
with another ball [__] i choked your
ass out with that goddamn turtleneck on
[__] ass well i was calling them
everything yo i was mad i was really mad
that was my that's my boo story
i i went home and you know like i was
going through some lady problems you
know my period was on schema french and
you don't [__] with no one when they
stuck [__] cyclone right i was going
crap i already had homeowner problem
then you hit a [__] in the head with a
with a nerf ball and my hormones messing
up
dude i went i couldn't believe it but we
i used to have it on video it's the
funniest [__] in the world
i want to look through my house cause i
told my husband i took it home and my
kids laughed at me so hard
they were on the floor it's the funniest
[__] i need to find that vcr tape that
would go viral now it probably wouldn't
go far
miss pat get smacked in the face with a
nerf ball
dude i couldn't believe it i could not
[__] believe that man that never fall
was that before you started doing your
true stories and everything yes that's
back when i was like i suck dick
i hate them kind of jokes i don't suck
dick i got vertigo
well you started comedy before you even
knew what it was your caseworker was
like your stories are hilarious you
should get on stage and do stand up but
then she didn't really say
she said you should tell these stories i
was like i'm not telling my business it
takes a lot as a comic to open up
because when you open up like that you
allow people to into your life into your
secrets that you always had and never
really told nobody but i found it i
found it to be
a way for me to heal when i when i can
openly tell you and i'm not embarrassed
anymore that i had two kids by a married
man at 14. then that that that allowed
me to hear heal and also that allowed me
to not let that situation have control
over me comedy helped me get over a lot
of this [__]
well i've heard you say you know you can
only talk about what you have forgiven
yes and that doesn't have control over
you anymore exactly but you mean you
i mean you really have every reason to
you know be angry be angry and bitter
you look at it i mean i can look at it
and say oh well society let me down but
you know i i started to tell myself you
know you're only going to get out of
life what you put into life and i got
that a lot i got that saying from
get up and get out and get something
from outcast
and my husband was like don't nobody oh
you [__] stop feeling sorry for you
nobody had never told me that they don't
tell you that in the ghetto they don't
all they say oh no you can't get up out
the ghetto yes you can you know what's
crazy i'll just visit my sister and she
living the way i we used to live as kids
and i called my husband i said you know
what i realized that the ghetto the
ghetto
the hood is like the desert don't
nothing grow don't nothing grow what the
[__] grow in the desert
dust thank you and that's what them
[__] look like dusty
i'm sorry i had to get my cousin i had
to go get my cousin and i was like come
take your pistol with me to go see my
sister in the head
geez
i mean honestly i got on a ring that i
don't want stolen and i love my
relatives but i'm like i'm not going
over there by myself and i don't have no
gun i'm a convicted felon so she put up
45 in her pocketbook and i went to go
tell my sister hey and i love her
how are you able to forgive i mean just
one example that comes to my mind is
like your dad the first time you meet
him you're 11 he beats you thinking
you're
your sister
and then you don't meet him again until
the late 20s
but then you take care of them yes i
can't tell you that yes i did i mean how
did
i mean there's there's no role model
even suggesting that to be an option how
do you forgive
because i don't hold grudges see when
you hold grudges and when you hate it
controls you like people like how do you
talk to your baby daddy he beat you he
shot you he did all these things to you
because i don't know how to hold a
grudge i don't know how to hate
i know how not to [__] with you but i
don't know how to hate
i mean haters are strong haters a strong
word for you to say i hate you so every
time you go see that person or think
about that person that person bring pain
to you so why am i'm gonna hate you i
don't want you that i don't want you to
bring pain to me every time i think
about you
you know so i just i i don't i don't
hold a grudge i just i look at life like
this if it's bigger than me then i give
it to my god
and i don't have control over what
people have done to me i can only
control what i can control what's in
front of me now i can't go back and say
hey why y'all do all this [__] to me for
what what i'm gonna be sitting around
crying over that [__] for if it do
it's not gonna allow me to grow i'm
happy i'm smiling you looking at a [__]
you've been [__] hit uh beat shot
molested everything and i smile every
day and don't none of that [__]
cross my mind with a negative vibe i'm
writing a book uh my mama did some
[__] up [__] to us and i'd be like
hold on y'all that's still my [__]
mama because i don't hate my mama see
you gotta you gotta realize a lot of
this [__] is a lot of all of this [__]
is a cycle that's what i had to realize
it's a cycle what you know you pass down
to your kids if you don't learn [__]
then all you can pass down to your kids
is what you know so that's what happened
my mama is from generation to generation
nobody learned [__] so they kept passing
down [__]
but one day i was like y'all ain't this
[__] ain't about to suck my kids up so i
started to surround myself around better
people i'm sorry i needed somebody who
said who i could say what did word right
here mean or how to spell this
[Laughter]
so i mean that's why i'm not angry i'm
happy i'm forgiving my baby daddy for
you know for beating on me for shooting
me for [__] really molesting me had
two kids by married man at 15. i've
forgiven my mama i've forgiven my daddy
i've forgiven a lot of people they don't
even know it i'm happy i'm doing good
did your second grade teacher have any
influence a big influence miss troupe
she had a big influence
i think she put the hustle in me she
made me believe even when i was doing
time in jail and i was at my lord's law
i always quoted what she said ms trump
said patricia you could be anything in
the world you want to be all you got to
do is believe have a dream and i tell my
husband today i said you i said y'all
think i'm spontaneous but i've all these
i was like you just jump up and do [__]
no i've been dreaming about this [__]
i've been feeling it i've been putting
it in the universe i believe everything
if i want something my dad was like i
tell my husband i'm gonna get that he
was like yeah and he look up and i get
it
he think i'm playing that's just how i
work i believe i mean that lady told me
that she's in the bathroom when i was
like second third grade and she just
died last year and i still quote her and
i still thank her to this day
and she was definitely a mother figure
yeah she called my hair she brushed my
teeth she gave me clean clothes
i mean she let me know that
when i go home [__] is [__] up but
things can get better
and you've done the same for a lot of
kids too yeah i was just with my cousin
my cousin we just walked and uh i told
her i said i said i'm putting you in the
book because my cousin i go over my own
house oh i don't know i probably i'm
probably 16 at the time with two kids
and my cousin is being raised in the
situation i was in so i tell my until i
say why don't you let boo come live with
me and she's like okay cause she already
had like eight children and everybody
having babies so boo come live with me
and at this time i'm a big i'm a good
i'm a
i'm a big time drug dealer not the
kingpin type but i'm making good money
to be 16.
so i teach my niece how to do sell drugs
we cut it we do everything together
after i break off from the mind you i'm
16 so my cousin is four years younger
than me so what's that 10
four years younger than me yesterday
yeah what's that 12 12. she's 12. god
damn it take me that long took all of us
that long
so she's 12 years old and she's selling
drugs with me she's just selling drugs
with me
and so she get about 14
and uh she take a dope case for me the
police are determined to get me so she
go to juvenile and she get pregnant and
she go to juvenile and she do the time
for me and i told her today i said i put
you in a book i just want to tell you
i'm sorry i [__] up your life and she
told me she said [__] you saved me she
said cause i could be like your sister i
could be like my sister yeah i took a
dope charge from you but you taught me a
lot of [__] about the hood
and i almost teared up cause i to me i
[__] her life up she went to jail for
two years she gave birth to her first
child in jail she got pregnant she was
all the [__] she was just we was just
doing the cycle you know you know high
school dropout we both dropped out she
ended up getting her ged later on too
and she owned a tie shop nandicator and
i was like i [__] your life up and she
was like no you didn't you saved me i
said yeah i saved you for one thing but
i put you and i put you in some
dangerous situation she was like well
you family
she said you taught me a lot even though
you want to you want to admit it and i
think about that all the time that's
what that's what [__] me up about the
whole drug dealing because i brought so
many other kids that i was trying to
help but i was a kid myself i'm not
making excuses for me but i [__] up
their life i got another niece who who
who i left she's still selling drugs i
don't know i don't think she's doing it
to this day but i got another niece that
when we used to [__] do other legal
[__] i got her locked up and then they
took the drug charges with me but you
know she's good she's working she got a
good job she's in texas now but i've
asked them all i tell them i said i
[__] your life up i introduced y'all
to [__] y'all shouldn't have been
introduced to but then i was like rabbit
you saved us
because their mama was on drugs and [__]
and
they look at him being saved but i
looked at i could have did a better job
but again i was only 16.
but you also helped kids
not only
in like the drug realm but didn't you
also run a concession stand at one time
yeah
you helped you hired kids to work that
way inner city yeah cause i lived in
riverdale so a lot of those kids was
just
you know they didn't
i never worked with a group of dumbass
people in my life i'm being i cannot
believe today's use they dummies for
them kids could even get them counting
change back without the register i'm
like oh [__] 52-cent count from
52. and i own up to a dollar they didn't
know [__] so i taught them a lot a lot
of them you know they went on to date
most of them went on to college a lot of
them went on to do good things in life
most of them got good jobs but i mean a
lot of them the parents was you know
when you're in the inner city most of
them singing parents household the one
parent is working their ass out so it's
kind of hard to raise a kid so a lot of
them like hung around me because i'm a
stay i was a stay-at-home mom i just
went to the dome and [__] and so but
talking to them there was some they were
some stupid [__]
but and i kept it real with them and
that's what they like about me i tell
them they was like they would go around
i said well if you're just gonna give
somebody your [__] then what do you
have i mean you you gonna let somebody
you're gonna go and have sex with
somebody and then they disrespect you
and that's what they had no value they
just thought oh everybody having sex i'm
supposed to have to say well when this
[__] get you ace what happened
when you get a baby [__] you cannot
stick a baby back up your [__] baby
it's not a tampon okay when it's out is
out
and i just told them [__] like that i
was like you know stand up for yourself
don't ever let nobody walk over you i've
never seen a group of weak minded
[__] in my life because i mean
i guess cause i raised myself and like
they would they would bow down to my
daughter cause my daughter my daughter
was like my daughter a [__] a push
show she she liked to push people over
and i told her i said look y'all don't
have to bow down to my daughter because
y'all work for me cuss this [__] out
don't let her talk to y'all and then you
let me cuss you out but don't let my
daughter cuss you out okay
so just a lot of that
and they still think me to this day it's
like i learned a lot from you but i just
kept it real with them you know like
when um i have a kid he's a preacher his
name is antonio and uh antonio was uh
he was in line to be valedictorian
riverdale high which is not a big deal
because he [__]
[Laughter]
he's dealing with all black kids on 3.0
making valedictorian
so we say now
and um antonio thought he was better
than all the other kids and i told
antonio i said tony yo you know you want
to have your nose in the air and you
only want to hang out with the smart
kids what you think is smart i say and
the dumb kids you don't want to be
bothering them i said but when you get
out in the real world you got to deal
with all kind of people i mean from
oprah 11 down to a [__]
crackhead you got to know how to talk to
all people so if you don't know how you
only know how to talk to one group of
people then
your life is limited [__] i
don't give a [__] on me all the time i'm
gonna talk to obama i can talk to obama
and i can talk to a crackhead my
crackhead system and i ain't got to
change who i am i said but you i said
you need to find out who you are you
pretending to be something that you not
i said so all you i said don't don't
don't [__] close people out because
you feel like they can't use them on
nice ass words you use they don't mean
[__] when you're [__] when your
character rich is [__] up when the
person you really are inside is [__]
up i said won't you treat everybody the
same whether they dumb smug black white
green with one eye in their [__] head
treat everybody the same
and i talked to him a couple of couple
of months ago he said that's one thing i
learned from you we we all the same
and we all the same i mean ain't nothing
different i'm fatter than you you white
i'm black you probably got a college
degree and i probably know how to cook
cocaine that's the only thing different
that's why they call you miss pizzle
the kids did call me miss pilzor
yes i hated that [__] oh really
that was before snoop dogg doing the the
drizzles and all that i don't know what
them kids got there from they caught my
my son now he called me miss pizzle and
he called me juicy
i hate that you don't call your [__]
mama juicy that's nasty
not to him he'll come what's up juice i
said don't call me juicy [__] so and
we're close in age
yeah so when we go out i always look
like a cougar with him
and i have to tell people i'm not
[__] him this is my son stop putting
this ball on me he dum his [__] i don't
[__] people who can go more than twice
i'm sorry did y'all get that
oh we're getting it all
right we're getting it all i love your
honesty and you're
you're a natural-born hustler i mean
eva it's i mean it's in your jeans your
mom would take the family around to
different churches
and get baptized yeah so they would pay
the bills and the food yeah it started
before that yeah it started with granada
bootleg house
that's as far as i can remember
my granddaddy sold bootleg looker so i
mean the hustler came from there you
know like
i'm quite sure you heard the story how i
had to steal out of people's pocket and
my mom would pay me five dollars per
person
that's a lot of money for eight-year-old
to go play pac-man and so
i've never seen nobody with no job
literally i was talking to my cousin yes
that's it do you know
that
nobody has a job in our family nobody
has a career my cousin owned a tie shop
my brother is a fake-ass mechanic
he fixed people calls and changed his
phone number
and
he thinks people causing chain they
phone them because he ain't right he is
not right
and everybody else is just living off
the system i got an uncle there's a
mechanic and i told my cousin i was like
literally nobody has a career other than
i have a comedy career she got a tie
shot and my brother uh my brother's a
fake ass mechanic and i'm looking at
like my my granddaddy
kids he had eight kids and i'm looking
at all of them the one that's not in
jail
nobody really has a career
wow you do i have a career yes cause i
don't [__] with them
[Laughter]
my cousin on the top shop she's doing
really well so she i mean she has
something going on but it's just there's
three people that i can think of those
tough experiences have certainly paid
off i mean by 15 you have two kids
you've been shot twice
you're not only a crack dealer you're
like
the plug
on the block you're running it you're
making like 10 grand a week doing this
yeah i made a lot of money sometime a
day yeah so like how how is that hustle
carried over into the comedy game ah
that's a good question
i use the same i use the same tactics
like you got to get up you got when
everybody else is sleeping you got to be
putting your [__] product together
which is jokes now it's still a crack
like literally if i come home from an
open mic or i come home i come from a
show i literally get out my laptop and
if i if i've been working on anything i
go right to work on it um
uh i don't have a problem with going to
open mic you know some people think i
ain't got time for the open mic [__] i
don't have a problem if i fly into a
state earl if i see you got an open mic
and i'm your headliner i would ask the
club hey let me come close out there
open mike just cause i want to work on
[__] it's the same hustle you know the
early bird catches the room i wait i
still wake up at i mean i go to the gym
a lot now so i literally get up at three
o'clock and go to the gym and then i
[__] come back to my hotel room i get
back in bed and i work on my laptop
were there any bad habits you had to
break no i never did drugs never smoke
eating is my [__] bad habit can't you
see it all in my face and ass
i just mean from the hustle side of it
were there any things that didn't carry
over you had to
kind of get away from yeah jail
jail jail okay she won't go to jail for
being too funny
no you won't go to jail for that [__]
just uh you know like breaking the law
and and uh
when when you hustling like that
everything comes fast and when you're
earning your money the right way
everything comes slow so that's what
that's with a shocker right now because
my husband straight out of the military
always had a job and i'm like he was
like you need to quit selling drugs and
[__] you don't get a job and i'm like
[__] why they do that
you know what i do today i'm 16 years
old with a 2 000 pocketbook what do they
do that ass i'm gonna do that kind of
[__] but he kept so i would say that's
the bad habit you know i always want to
find a hustle so that's why i started
doing the dome and that's why i started
doing other [__] and and i you know i
never really just had a really
a job it's always had to be for myself
even when i worked at general mode i was
like this [__] too slow for me my was
like oh this 22 now [__] that [__] you
put that [__] all in the back of that
car i'm gonna go find something on my
own to do and he couldn't get it he
couldn't get it i said because i like to
be in control
i like to be in control i like to say
this is what i'm gonna do
or i don't want to do that when you had
a job you got to clock in and do the
same [__] over and over again i hate
doing the same [__] over and over again
the great part about being a comedian at
least you can change your outfit or at
least you can start from the back of
your set and go to the front of your set
or you can start in the middle with a
job you and like building a car is the
same [__] over and over again just
watching people get old i'm not a
[__] or old people watcher
i like living i like doing [__] but my
husband you don't mind doing it
but that reliability of your husband has
certainly been the turning point in your
life [__] yeah he's he's a foundation
when i was going out doing open mics and
brought me a plane ticket so i can go to
missouri and do an open mic what the
[__]
you don't get it you understand this
[__] is real he's like but he would
complain but he would do it he was doing
i mean honestly he's been the foundation
of my career
i always call him a hater because he
don't think i'm funny
and he never really thought i was fun
he's like telling the [__]
chicken coop jokes
[Laughter]
he's not laughing anymore because a lot
of things is beginning to happen but in
the beginning when he had to take his
credit card out and you know [__] fly
me in the book too to do an open mic or
try to showcase for a gig or i'm driving
somewhere and only making 50 but don't
want to tell him won't make no damn
money but he didn't understand that side
of of it you know all he knows i punch
in i make a certain amount of money it's
always going to be there with comedy you
don't get the same amount of money in
the beginning
i mean never you really get the same
amount of money everybody offer you what
they think you work and some in the
beginning it was 50 how the hell are you
gonna drive to heinzville for fifty
dollars
uh that's fifty dollars
[__] the fifty dollars it's stage time
and he can understand how valuable the
stage time was versus
the money
like
literally if i do a tv interview they're
gonna pay you i say shut the [__] up i
don't get paid for in a tv interview
that's what he don't understand yeah i
just drove nine hours to kokomo indiana
for a hundred dollars so oh you drove
out there where i was at
yeah yeah
but your your husband was at least a
comedy fan because you guys did meet at
a comedy show
it was comedy karaoke it was comedy
karaoke yeah we went to go see bruce
bruce lip-syncing
lip-sync is that a backstage no oh okay
oh yeah that was backstage what you know
about backstage i know about backstage
ah it's a laundromat now
i'm out here
i'm on the hustle it was it was like a
little hot spot and i want to say it was
like a friday night and bruce bruce was
hosting and they had comedians and they
had lip syncing and boy we went there
that night and he just i knew his
brother already and he sat across the
table i said hey fat boy you want to
split some wings and so we started
talking and he didn't know that i had a
nail hiring baby daddy sign out
so i needed a baby daddy and i was like
oh he got back teeth ching ching i'm
gonna get him
but not only his reliability but with
his job having the reliable job at gm it
took him up to indianapolis where really
my career took a turn huge pivot yes
white people
it was it was not the scenery here that
i was used to in atlanta and i tell you
moving to indianapolis probably i don't
know moving to indianapolis saved my
career because god no i probably would
be somewhere going in circus it was
there when i went to the comedy club and
you know one of the managers was like
you really got some good i would tell
them about my life but not on stage like
you should say that on stage not like
this [__] ain't funny
he's like yes it is funny and so we were
just talking and and
by being at morty's day county
they helped me started to put my set
together you know my friend avery
diligent who works there still there and
he started to help me put my set
together to to for me to have something
to talk about other than roaches and you
know [__] that you hear a lot of
black comics talk about so it allowed it
opened my eyes moving to indianapolis
really opened my eyes i had no i no idea
that a
joke consists of uh um
um opening middle and ending
a premise so
you if you ever go to a black club you
see a lot of black comedian all they got
is a premise a funny-ass prim is like oh
that joke is funny no [__]
that's just a premise yeah it's a good
idea
it's a good idea good start good start
but there's nothing there yeah my
girlfriend got hit by a car oh [__] po
chop well what the rest of the jokes
why your girlfriend got hit by a car why
your girlfriend eat pork chop what
happened after your girlfriend they
don't a lot of them don't go there so
and that's what come that's what i
learned from being in indianapolis
it's actually the craft the craft of it
yeah you know and and just freeing
myself on stage just you know
not being ashamed of what i went through
that's when i really started talking
about who i was and i and i thought
people couldn't relate but i was wrong
it don't matter where you come from who
you are it's something in my city that
you can relate to if it didn't happen to
you you know a [__] who had a
baby young you know somebody who's on
welfare you know somebody who did this
you know somebody who did that i don't
give a [__] if it's just a mammogram
joke everybody got titties all the women
got titties right i don't care if your
titties are gone you remember when you
had titties right so
that's how i try to write you know i and
i don't go out to get a certain group of
people i just tell you about me
i probably can't get you as a fan and
personally i don't give a [__] you know
what can i do i can't say shake you up
in there i want you to think i'm funny
personally i don't give a [__] i'm a
grown ass woman i just got to do what i
do and keep it moving
everybody i had to learn that
everybody's not gonna like you as a
comedian i wanted everybody to like me
but i started thinking well [__] my own
real daddy didn't like me so why am i
chasing these [__] that i don't
know i didn't know my real dad and i
didn't chase his ass
so i was like [__] it i i don't care if
you like me and that shows the
resilience of your character and that
you're pretty much raised to almost be
scared of white people
yeah i was very scared of them well my
mama said uh she used to say [__] like
uh white people is better than you don't
ever look them in the eye they're the
devil and you know of course you know
black people think y'all the devil
yeah i don't think you're the devil but
that's how i was raised don't ever look
them and this like they're better than
me so when i moved to indianapolis and
i'm at a mainstream club i'm no longer
at uptown i'm in a place where i might
be the only [__] black person in the
club beside one of the other owners and
i look up and
and it would just then i would come off
stadium like oh my god you're so funny i
would look away because i would talk to
look away right and
they would make me nervous and he was
like oh you so funny i said i said get
your [__] hand on me before i choke
the [__] out of you this is what i would
say to myself because i was nervous i
mean i've never really had any
interaction with white people other than
going to jail and it and it wasn't y'all
thought i went to jail i [__] commit
a crime but when you're in jail is you
know
honestly the population is mostly black
people
so i i never really interact with them
until i moved to indianapolis and you
also made fun of comics doing the white
rooms you'd say oh you're going and
getting that white money
well that's what we used to say yeah
like people like drew drew never was on
the upside down upside uptown side so we
were like drew over there getting that
white money [__] him because that's all
i knew you know those are the people
that i knew but when i when i started to
realize what real comedy was and when i
got to indianapolis and when i got over
my whole fear of what i was taught and i
was like
she
you know if you write if you write
material
if you write good material you get all
types of people that like you right from
all no matter what color they are so i
stopped i i never tried to chase white
people i never tried to chase black
people i just wanted to be funny but
just so half of my my my comedy
i got a lot a lot more white fans than i
do black fans now because of what i do
and i don't do like a lot of the black
show they don't call me for that i'm
just as funny as anybody else but right
now i don't get called for that kind of
stuff but i mean i got a few but not as
many as i do caucasian fans i don't know
how this [__] happened this is the
craziest [__] in the world to me
one of the craziest things to me is just
the segregation of comedy
very i think with with the black comics
i think a lot of them like me you know
they they think white people are not
gonna get it you know
and you gotta admit a lot of the lingo
we use
like the way young people talk today i
have no [__] idea what they saying
i'm like what are you trying to say just
speak [__] ebonics or correct english
what is this slang [__] i don't get it
so
if you if you wouldn't if you are black
comedian and you using [__] that people
ain't used to hearing every day they're
not going to get your joke
you know i mean or you do you watching
something that everybody is not watching
okay everybody watch the game of thrones
right
but don't everybody watch the real
housewives of atlanta i'm black if
you're on stage talking about the real
housewife of allah i don't know what the
[__] you talking about because i don't
watch the real housewives of atlanta
that's what i'm saying the gang of
thrones
way more people of all races watch
housewives of atlanta only
certain that's a small circle so i think
with black comics we get we we get to
thinking well they're they're never
going to get who we are but that's not
true
if you're making your [__] if you're
making your [__]
uh
big enough uh what's the word i'm
looking for you know [__] random
looking universal yes universal enough
to talk about something everybody might
be familiar with michael jackson is
universal right [__] um
future just only a certain amount of
people know who the [__] that is you can
go all around the world and talk about
michael jackson but you can't go all
around the world and talk about no
[__] future because it don't
work like that so that's how comedy is
where you know
if you talking about rap to me i don't
know the [__] you talking i don't listen
to rap me i list the phone like t.i
tupac
[__] llc when they had something to
say these [__] ain't got [__]
[__] your gold chain [__] your call you
rented for this video and [__] your hoes
it's paying off though on a last comic
standing yep you were one of the few
comics that got
a like a feature where they interview
your family and things what was the
qualification for that did you did they
all through that afterwards or was this
all part of the deal uh once i got once
i got accepted on the show and um they
just called me up one day and said tell
me what's unique about your family i
said we all fat
but
we don't have diabetes at least the kids
don't read now and they just said we
would like to come out to your house and
do uh you know to meet your family and
stuff so i said okay come on out
my kids want to be on tv yeah so my
daughter came up from atlanta and my um
they came out and it was hilarious did
you see it did you see that my daughter
was so [__] funny on that yeah she's
funny anyway i try to get her to do open
mic she won't she just scared her
she's 17.
her whole dream is going to ivy league
school and be the first child uh her mom
and dad had that has a uh college degree
so
her whole thing is about whooping all
the other kids there to say oh i told
y'all i was better than y'all yeah yeah
and she's very
she's very political she like she
watched a lot of cnn i asked her the
other day she's always talking about
what's going on in the country and so i
told her i said you got to stop watching
so much cnn because if you keep watching
so much cnn it's gonna make you it's
gonna make you one-minded like people
who watch fox yep
yeah so she was like i saw i asked i
said are you racist
she said no i'm not racist um but i'm
she said i'm not racist but um i'm race
conscious so i said what the [__] is
race conscious she said um she said i
know what white people think of black
people i said well what do white people
think of us she said they think we all
uh
all lazy and unemployed so i said well
garriana
you are lazy and you unemployed
i just saw you exactly what white people
think you are she got so mad she's like
i'm not talking about me i said but you
black and you say that's what they think
about you right
[Laughter]
she was [__] she would live it she
was so mad at me i said boy if you if
you think that's the way somebody think
about a race of people or your race of
people why didn't want you won't you
prove them wrong why don't you prove
rising but you are lazy and you are
unemployed you're lazy as [__] i try to
get you a job you said no because
technically i was responsible for you to
you was 18. which is [__] genius
can't help smart miss pizza yeah
she is she's just something else so
she got so mad i was like you are lazy
and you [__] are unemployed so you're
exactly what you think white people
think you are
well they have a mom that works
extremely hard and it's starting to pay
off i'm so
happy with how your career is going
right now
just seeing the positive feedback you
got on last comic standing all the
judges loved it the audience loved it
there seemed to be a moment between you
and roseanne like do you guys have a
history together yeah i used to open uh
i did a show called
royal funniest mom and roseanne took me
out to vegas and open for a couple of
shows so yeah i do kind of have a
history rules and i like roseanne i
always pray one day that i get a sitcom
and it's it's like i'm the i'm the like
roseanne but a little bit more edgy so i
pray that that happened one day what
would you call the sitcom mrs pat shaw
[Laughter]
i'm gonna need to work at this
[__] ever get counsel
is that one of those kind of like how
you dreamed from miss troop telling you
can dream and make it happen is this one
of those things you're dreaming that
you're gonna make happen i've always
yeah i've always dreamed that i was
having my own sitcom one day i always
dreamed that i would be selling out of
theaters one day and my whole dream is
to come up through the floor and pray
that the lyft don't stop because i'm too
heavy
i'll keep saying oh i need to change
that dream cause i know that [__]
lymph is gonna think i'm too happy
and it's just gonna stop halfway then
they gonna see my big ass crawling not
to flow
that would go viral
i bet it would too
well before the sitcom even comes out
you have a book coming out which you
being an 8th grade dropout now releasing
a book
i didn't write the book people i have a
i have a writer okay i write a goddamn
book i told the story but i have a book
coming out through harper collins they
purchased it last year which i'm really
excited about because i mean because you
know i do a lot of podcasts and a lot of
stories that i cannot tell on stage it's
just not it doesn't fit the stage and
you know in this book people really get
to get to know who i am what i went
through and the books start with saying
have an open mind before you want to
judge because i did some [__] up [__]
in my life and i lay it all out in this
book i mean i went through some
difficult times and you know i put drugs
in my kids draws i made some major
mistakes out i tell people i said well
you can admit that you was a horrible
mom in the beginning i was a [__]
horrible mom yes i was 16. i was 15 with
two kids but that's no excuse some of
this [__]
i don't even know if i knew better i
wish i had known better
like selling drugs in front of her
school
had an excuse my biggest excuse was
well i was here i i was actually there
before the no school drug signs went up
so when it's when the signs went up i
was already grandfathered in
[Laughter]
so technically you can't [__] with
nobody who was there before you right
well that's how i laugh at that
situation i said technically i was
grandfathered and grandfathered in you
tell the judge that yeah yeah i get more
time [__] you tell my school zones no
selling drugs in schools i was here
before you thought of this stupid [__]
and putting them little babies on that
[__] side what are you talking about
judge
you had your way around the law was
there any sort of like back door deals
you were able to work out with a like
judge or something with your pool um i
just had a good lawyer
dinner shots he's still here in atlanta
what was the energy man
i was gucci man he was my [__] lawyer
first
[Laughter]
i met him i met him we had just got
became a lawyer he used to be a police
officer yeah he used to be a police
officer and i met dennis he was just him
no secretary smaller office but had a
good reputation with getting drug
dealers bond this was back when when you
first went to jail for drugs on atlanta
back in the early 90s they didn't really
know the [__] whole thing of it you
know how how crazy it was so you could
just get a bun right off the bat when i
got locked up you didn't get a bun right
off the bat they had changed it like two
years later so i met then shot through
another drug dealer who had got out and
i tell dennis shaw all the time say
[__] i gave you a career i hooked you
up in the hood
i took you to every drug dealer every
friend i had they got arrested i said
call dennis shot and i tell him that all
the time i still i talked to him about
six months ago
yeah and he thanks you
just like everybody who the [__] you
talking about rabbit still called me rap
i said my name is no [__] rabbit okay
stop calling me rabbit
so he's like i was like i gave your ass
a career that's why you so popular in
atlanta
that's why all the drug dealers and
murderers knowing
because of you
uh yeah the old school
and the name just kept traveling when
you do a good job your name travel
is he in the book like is that one of
those stories
he was so sexy man i said oh you look
like a beautiful superman just cuter but
i think dennis had him fell out he's
older now uh what was i 17 when i first
got arrested so didn't dennis had to be
because his kids was baby they they they
groaned and married now
wow yeah that's how long i've been
knowing
i mean these stories in the book are
some of them ones you tried on stage but
they weren't funny so you have to save
them for the book no they just never
stay no just not stage material i mean
there's only so much you can put on
stage that people take be like god damn
like sometimes i perform and people
people want to cry i would love to know
since you're you have all these great
stories some of them are worthy of stage
i know you've said you learned how to
tell stories from bill cosby yes and
richard pryor so could you can maybe
give a little inside baseball in that
process well i have a next-door neighbor
when i in riverdale when i first started
doing comedy and he was like your voice
is raspy like mom maybelline i had never
heard of mom maybe because i was not a
comedy person and i was sitting on my
back porch when i first started doing
hoping mikey just tell the story to my
next-door neighbor who's a big comedy
person
and um and i would tell him he's like
you got stories like richard pryor and i
heard richard pryor named first like
through my caseworker because she was
like you know
rit you funny like richard pryor oh your
stories are like richard pryor so my
neighbor kept saying it and i had
already googled him so i said well i
need to learn how to tell a [__]
story but i really didn't know how to
put it together so when i moved out to
indianapolis i mean i started looking at
bill cosby but i couldn't get it i would
see these stories and how he would loop
him around and bring him back i don't
know how the [__] did he do that but
once i got to indianapolis around people
who kind of
was familiar with that type of comedy
then i started to learn how to just tell
stories i'm still learning i'm nowhere
as good as they are but uh neither one
of them i wish
you know bill cosby so put you in when
bill cosby is so sorry for all the [__]
he's going through
but um when he tell a story it's almost
like you right there with him and that's
what i want people to get i want you
it's no matter what race you are i want
you to be in that local house and see
how [__] up this situation is and
still laugh at it
so can you do that just on a minor
adjustments like just use a joke example
from last comic standing
how
you talk about
how you're running away from somebody
shooting at you and the old old version
of the joke is you saying it was 20
years ago when they built strong fences
but on last comic standing you say you
ran through the fence does that give a
more visual cue to the audience is that
why you change it
you've really been studying me um
jumping over the fence is the original
version yes when i did it for comedy
central
i changed it to running through the fisk
so it was a little bit more funnier you
know jokes is even though it's how truth
i am you still have to tweak it a little
bit
and i when i did it the newer way it got
a bigger laugh because people can
actually see your big ass ain't jumping
on no fence you might have ran through a
face so you can see my big ass running
through a fence in the head so just for
visual matters
yeah so that's that's how jokes work
you know you still keep the truth there
but you still have to twerk it a little
bit
twerk it yeah twerk it up tweak it is it
tweak it well twerk is the the booty
shaking dance oh well you can do that
too too if that's what you like so tweak
it so that's how you you have a baseline
story and then you'll just embellish
certain
if i need to yeah because some of it
like my stories are [__] up stories so
it's gonna make you cringe and i can
tell the people like when they huh and
they hold him back
uh
okay i can give you a better example
okay i got shot in the head by my baby
daddy right so for years i could never
get people to laugh at that joke and i
was like this is funny to me everything
is funny to me
and
my man is like it's not funny for a dude
to shoot a woman in the back of the head
i said something there is funny so i
kept playing around with it so one day i
said you know my kid's father i said
i've been through a lot of my life my
kids father shot me in the back of the
head immediately everybody like what the
[__] right i said but don't worry it was
not his fault
it was my fault cause i dunked slow
they're like what the [__] did she just
say that yeah but i did get shot in the
back of my head and then of course it
was not my fault but i couldn't get
people to laugh at it okay and i thought
it was funny like some of this horrible
[__] in my life and my man was like this
[__] ain't funny [__] you you don't know
what it is to be black in america it's
funny to me
and that's how i look at it well i don't
i don't want you give away all your
secrets here miss pat um
but before we get out of here you've
been so generous with your time
uh do you have anything else you want
the world to know
no other than the book is coming out and
you know check me out on twitter
i don't do a lot of instagram but i'm
there yeah i don't take pictures of my
food i don't have time to [__] um
and i'm also on facebook and it's
comedienne
miss pat m-s-p-a-t just follow me and
and when when you post it i'll be more
than happy to
uh
tweet you know retweeting absolutely
[__] like that and the book is still
gonna be called rabbit it's still gonna
be called rabbit yes it is it was your
childhood nickname and it was my drug
dealing name it was my drug dealing name
so it it'll be it'll be pretty
interesting
wow well that's gonna be selling them
out the trunk too
[Laughter]
old habits die hard
i'm gonna be selling about the trunk i
just think i can do a better job than
the bookstore
that's that hustling that's that street
yeah the street smarts yes it is well
thank you for your time thank you for
having me